I had one habit that I developed when I was at college.
It was actually a very bad habit which was...
...I liked to show people that I didn't do any work.
And that I didn't go to classes and I didn't care, and then at the very last minute,...
...like, two days before the test, I get serious about it.
And people thought that was funny.
You know, that was my positioning:...
...the guy who did nothing until the last minute.
Then when I went into business, that was a really bad habit.
And it took me a couple years to get over that.
Nobody praised me because I would do things at the last minute.
And I tried the reverse to students I'd actually...
...I didn't think that highly of, who were always organized and had things done on time.
I'm still working on it,...
...but procrastination is not a good habit.